there's a lot more to the Nevada
Department of transportation's I-15
Tropicana project than that diverging
diamond we constantly talk about traffic
anchor Nate dannenbaum with a look ahead
and what's driving you crazy
[Music]
while they are busy tweaking that
diverging diamond interchange on
Tropicana over the I-15 and starting to
rebuild the destroyed North half of the
street you know there is a little
something something else started to
happen just to the north it's right
there at Harmon over the freeway well
indot's about to start construction
there on what's called a half freeway
interchange going to look a lot like the
one up in the far Northwest Valley on
Elkhorn at us 95. now there are going to
be some overnight freeway lane closures
during that construction but really the
bigger story is that that half
interchange is scheduled to open
sometime in the fall which will
hopefully lessen the pain of the next
complete closures of both Trump and the
freeway when the South half of trop goes
bye-bye and drop a Canada 2.0 buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation we are traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com